i i want to thank
the folks in baltimore
and the folks in kansas city
because
we always had nothing today i don't know
what we're going to do we're going to
tell knock knock jokes i don't know
dirty limerick's possibly
uh but thank you because they could have
done it
during the draft they could have done it
over the weekend when people weren't
engaged but i really want to say thank
you to eric decosta and brett veach for
coming together and getting the deal
done that sends orlando brown who made
it clear
he's not a right tackle he's a left
tackle
wants to be a left tackle
chiefs need a left tackle there are the
full terms of the deal you know it's
funny
you no longer have
a guy traded for like a first-round pick
there's got to be all this extra stuff
like the little grains of rice that you
put on the scale to get it just right
this is one of those trades where well
okay it's orlando brown and a second
round pick and it's six round pick next
year we're gonna get the six round pick
next year and you get back
first round pick oh but also a third
round pick and a fourth round pick and
and oh
just to balance it out a fifth round
pick next year so that's
what happens but the main feature is
pick number 31 goes to baltimore and
orlando brown goes to kansas city and
now the chiefs have
a left tackle ostensibly who's entering
the last year of his contract with no
new deal to be done reportedly i saw
mortal reports to that effect and
it's a win-win but it's odd because even
though they're not in the same division
they are two of the top rivals in the
afc and there's a chance that that
orlando brown
could help the chiefs beat the ravens at
some point when it matters most in
january
uh yeah that's one of the most
interesting things about this other than
the fact that you know you need a lot of
bags of rice in order to balance out
anything with orlando brown because
that's a really big dude but i'll tell
you what mike i think that when you look
at what
orlando brown is going to bring to the
chiefs it's something that they really
really really needed because if you look
at that offensive line and we've talked
about this ad nauseam it went it was
very depleted by the time that they got
to the super bowl and so one of the
things i i think you gotta applaud brett
beach for is not just saying well we
have patrick mahomes and that's going to
cover her up for a lot no they had to
say we're going to go out there and
we're going to get better and they were
aggressive in getting a player that is
on a team that was in their conference
so if you have to trade you know a first
round pick and a couple other picks in
order to get that done and then you
still get a second round pick back i
think that that is something to be
applauded
and
the chiefs and the ravens do get
together in the regular season this year
in baltimore so orlando brown will be
back at some point we find out on may 12
when the
games will actually be we know the who
and the where we find out the win in a
few weeks
and remember last year early on
when the chiefs beat the ravens on a
monday night it was
lamar jackson who said the chiefs are
our kryptonite and they didn't get a
chance to have that rematch in the
postseason but
um
chief's a little bit better today and
the ravens picking up a first round pick
i thought that the vikings would be a
potential trade partner for the
baltimore ravens with orlando brown
because the vikings have that need as
well although they're thinking about
ezra cleveland
moving from guard to left tackle i yeah
they weren't ready to do it last year
and they kept riley reef i don't know
what's changed in a year but that was
the one i thought that would happen and
maybe the one you were hoping would
happen mike i don't know i don't know
that i was hoping it would happen
because i i don't i if the you know the
ravens
would have found a way to make it work
if they really wanted to keep them
because i don't think left tackle
is as important as it as it used to be i
think left and right are almost equally
important right it's not like this is a
high-flying passing game in baltimore
and lamar jackson doesn't need a ton of
protection for his blind side if orlando
brown's a great tackle you just pay him
and you keep him and you've got brown
and you got ronnie stanley so uh i i
just i i
i just wonder if the browns or not the
browns but the ravens in sending orlando
brown as opposed to orlando raven being
sent by the browns it's orlando brown
being by the ravens of the chiefs i just
wonder if the ravens are like yeah okay
you we'll go ahead we'll give one of our
top rivals in the conference a guy that
maybe we don't really believe in but the
chiefs do the chiefs have the need and
uh and the ravens now reportedly going
to sign alejandro villanueva the long
time left tackle in pittsburgh he
happily will become the right tackle in
baltimore after the draft they're going
to do that and i also know that
the way it works
there's a window after the draft where
the
signings no longer count
toward compensatory draft formulas and
the ravens one of the teams very adept
at playing that game
and
look it's unenforceable if someone else
out wants alejandro villanueva they can
sign him but wink nod villanueva is
waiting and at the right time the ravens
will sign him and then he's the guy who
replaces orlando brown that's simple
yeah it is so that's why the all the
moving parts in this are so very
interesting to me because you've got a
guy in villanueva who is coming down
from pittsburgh who's been a part of
that rivalry and you kept you know doing
the freudian slip with the browns and
the ravens thing and it like was little
pins and needles just going i wasn't
doing it on purpose every single time
yeah i know well we'll see if one of
these teams can pick their quarterback
of the future mike so how about that you
know maybe it won't be one of they won't
be the ravens or the chiefs or the
browns but one of these teams in the
draft is definitely going to pick a
quarterback of the future aren't they
let me let me say this to you right now
i didn't do it on purpose
but now that i know it bugs you
oh i will
i will i now have
my kryptonite to use on you
especially when you try to get smart
with me i finally found it i still don't
know when your birthday is i'll find
that out soon enough
but now i know all i have to do is call
the ravens the browns and off we go or
or i suppose if i could if i if i maybe
get a copy of the biography of art model
and read a chapter or two on the air oh
god
you know it would i'm sure it probably
would hurt people's ears more than it
would hurt mine uh but yeah anyway i
think with vodaueva going down to the
ravens what's going to be interesting to
see is how he adjusts to being right
tackle i think in that offense that is
so
run based it might be a little bit
easier than it would say going to
somewhere that's a pass heavy offense
because of the way you have to do things
differently when you're left tackling a
right to pack look people talk about it
sometimes and you know it is supposedly
easier being a right tackle than a left
tackle but setting as a pass protector
is very different when you're on the
right than when you're on the left it's
basically like you have to change
everything that's inside your brain
right so i think going to an offense
that is so run based is going to work
out well for villanueva because you're
just going straight ahead and you know
the the ravens can sign different wide
receivers you know they can go after
different guys in the draft and get a
different wide receiver and they
obviously do need to improve their
passing game but as long as you've got
lamar jackson who's got the kind of
wheels that he has you've got the guys
in the backfield that the ravens do
they're gonna continue to be your
running-based offense so from that
perspective i think that this is gonna
be a good signing for them whenever they
execute it
um i have heard the difference between
left tackle and right tackle explained
in some very graphic terms
that uh uh
uh well i don't know how it's not like
we can't say it we've said it on the
show before i think we said it on the
morning show
somebody and i can't remember who
said it's like wiping with your left
hand and then wiping with your right
hand that that's how different it is
that it's it's a dramatic change to your
existence and by the way i'm
multitasking here i'm on amazon looking
for
an art model biography there isn't one
maybe i should write one
maybe the world needs
an art model biography
my mom is in her car on the way home
right now and she is just so upset sorry
mom
mom sorry mom all right i'll stop
okay uh
the chiefs in shedding eric fisher the
number one overall pick in the 2013
draft and mitchell schwartz a two-time
all-pro they have added joe tooney free
agent from the patriots
kyle long came out of retirement he's
joining the chiefs
center austin blyth is uh now in the
fold and orlando brown
jr
the son of orlando brown who was a
browns tackle
and took that notorious bean bag in the
eye
from
who was the referee that threw
the bean bag i can see him
i can see him
i can hear his voice for my football
consciousness but i know i know who
you're talking about i don't know what
you're talking about but i i couldn't
tell you the referee's name
yeah wait a minute it was like 1999. you
were like eight years old you you don't
remember that come on man i remember it
happening but but do i remember the
specifics of all of that no i do not the
first football game i basically really
remember was a brown's preseason game in
that year and then when they beat the
saints
on uh halloween when tim couch threw a
hail mary to kevin johnson in the end
zone so that that that's what i remember
from 1999.
jeff triplett is the referee
through that fateful bean bag and
remember i mean if
brown went over and throw him down he
retired for like a year he sued the nfl
it was a big ugly nasty mess they could
write a book about that as well the
second volume to go along with the
biography of art model
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports